en este vídeo quiero cubrir varios temas
que están todos relacionados y en cierto
nivel son muy simples pero en su
conjunto tienden a confundir a la gente
así que espero tener algunos avances con
todos ustedes así que un buen lugar para
empezar es imaginar que hay algún tipo
de contenedor digamos aquí tienen
ustedes un contenedor aquí y que dentro
hay moléculas de agua voy a ponerlas con
este color digamos morado tenemos
entonces aquí moléculas de agua tengo un
montón de moléculas de agua y además voy
a tener muy algunas moléculas de azúcar
ok digamos por por sentar ideas algunas
moléculas de azúcar que ahí tienen sus
moléculas de azúcar y todas estas
moléculas están rebotando con entre
ellas este están están chocando están
frotando que hay entonces en este tipo
de situación vamos a tener que va a
haber más agua ok vamos a tener mucha
más agua vamos a hacerlo un poquito más
claro tenemos muchas más moléculas de
agua en este contenedor ok entonces
y vamos a tener voy a ponerlo entre
comillas voy a ponerlo más porque en
realidad estamos pensando en
concentraciones de sustancias ok y
quizás si no estás aún muy relacionado
con los términos de mol de moles de
polaridad y demás bueno pues puede que
te esté confundiendo así que mejor vamos
a dejarlo en términos muy muy
coloquiales como que hay más agua ok en
este caso el agua es que se dice que es
un solvente aunque el agua es
el solvente muy bien la sustancia que
hay digamos que que tiene mayor
concentración en donde es que se
presenta más esa es a la que le vamos a
llamar el solvente en otro caso tenemos
el azúcar el azúcar no va a ser solvente
si no se le va a conocer como soluto es
el soluto muy bien y en ese caso donde
tenemos mucha más agua que azúcar
decimos que el azúcar se ha disuelto en
el agua entonces el azúcar se ha
disuelto
se ha disuelto en el agua muy bien
entonces otra vez cuando decimos que el
azúcar se ha disuelto en el agua cuando
el azúcar está en menor concentración o
hay menos azúcar que agua en este
contenedor y por ser que por por por ser
o por tener menor concentración el
azúcar se le conoce como absoluto y al
agua como solvente entonces cuando uno
tiene este tipo de digamos de mezcla
entre agua y azúcar le vamos a llamar
que es una solución muy bien a todo esto
a este contenedor con el agua y el
azúcar le vamos a llamar solución
muy bien entonces las soluciones tienen
un solvente que en nuestro caso es el
agua tienen un soluto que en nuestro
caso es el azúcar y bueno todo esto
puede ser alguna especie de repaso para
ustedes pero yo voy a hacerlo por una
razón porque quiero hablar de una idea
de una idea muy importante y que es la
idea de difusión voy a hablar de
son muy bien y volveremos en un momento
al agua y el azúcar especialmente al
agua entonces ahora vamos a suponer que
tenemos un contenedor aquí digamos
tenemos un contenedor aquí y para sentar
ideas no no no voy a poner ahorita agua
y demás digamos que tenemos algunas
moléculas de alguna de algún gas no sé
este digamos que pueden ser oxígeno
digamos que que son moléculas de oxígeno
muy bien y digamos que esta es la
configuración actual de las moléculas en
este espacio negro pues hay vacío no hay
nada muy bien y bueno esto está actuando
con cierta temperatura las moléculas
están chocando tienen la energía
cinética eso quiere decir que las
moléculas están se están moviendo muy
bien todas estas se están moviendo y
bueno éstas también están chocando y van
iban rebotando
al azar digamos que hay unas con las
otras y por supuesto que las que están
de este lado es más probable que reboten
entre ellas y se vayan
hacia otra dirección digamos si estas
que están aquí a la izquierda y abajo
empiezan a rebotar estás con mayor
probabilidad van a ir alejándose hasta
ocupar el espacio de arriba a la derecha
ok entonces en general todo este
movimiento nos va a dar una nueva
configuración de cómo están distribuidas
las moléculas entonces estas de aquí
tienden a ocupar nuevos espacios y
empiezan a llenar este este espacio
nuevo
así que con el tiempo estas moléculas
que estaban sobretodo concentradas más
hacia hacia esta esquina inferior
empiezan a rebotar y ahí empiezan
digamos a llegar hasta a un equilibrio y
no voy a entrar mucho en detalle de lo
que el equilibrio significa podrás ver
los vídeos de termodinámica si tienes si
tienes interés por saber de este tipo de
cosas pero al final lo que el contenedor
va a tener es una configuración como
esta digo no no se puede garantizar que
va a ser de esta forma o que no va a
regresar a esta otra hay cierta
probabilidad de que eso ocurra pero
esencialmente en términos estadísticos u
otro probabilísticos al final la
distribución va a quedar bastante
bastante bien repartida y esto y esto es
de lo que se trata la difusión y
realmente solo es la difusión de
partículas o de moléculas digamos de una
baja concentración perdón de una alta
concentración aquí están concentradas
en digamos en este sector y se van
moviendo a zonas donde hay una menor
concentración ok esencialmente esto es
lo que nos está diciendo la difusión ok
y la concentración se puede medir por
ejemplo en en moles la moral molar y
that perdón y molar modalidad y todas
estas ideas pero las ideas son sencillas
en realidad estamos calculando cuánto
digamos el número de partículas que hay
por unidad de área o de espacio muy bien
y aquí tienes por ejemplo aquí aquí
tienes nada mientras que aquí tienes
muchas partículas con bajas y que juntas
en una pequeña proporción de espacios
entonces pueden imaginar otros
experimentos como éste por ejemplo vamos
a hacer una solución vamos a hacer algo
como esto
vamos a cambiar un poco nuestro
contenedor digamos ahora vamos a tener
dos contenedores aunque aquí va a estar
un contenedor de hecho vamos a regresar
un poco a la idea que teníamos de la
solución muy bien y aquí vamos a tener
otro contenedor muy bien esencialmente
piensen que son contenedores iguales y
aquí vamos a tener una especie de puente
vamos a tener una especie de puente
entre estos dos contenedores muy bien
aquí aquí por supuesto estábamos
hablando de de gases aquí vamos a
regresar a nuestro ejemplo de la
solución aquí tenemos muchas moléculas
de agua
muchas moléculas de agua por supuesto
aquí estamos haciendo dibujos sencillos
pero estamos pensando en millones y
millones de moléculas de agua muy bien
entonces digamos que tenemos estos dos
contenedores con agua y que están a la
misma a la misma altura que son
idénticos y ahorita solo vamos a tener
moléculas de agua entonces todas estas
están rebotando alrededor digamos en
direcciones aleatorias están rebotando
de esta forma y entonces lo que puede
pasar es lo siguiente no hay una presión
que varía mucho
y digo que no varían mucho porque la
altura es esencialmente la misma verdad
entonces estas moléculas pueden pasar de
la izquierda a la derecha muy bien
pueden estar aquí en medio también ahora
lo que vamos a hacer es agregar un
soluto en este en este esquema muy bien
entonces digamos que vamos a regresar a
nuestra idea de las moléculas de de
azúcar y digamos que tenemos estas estas
cuatro moléculas muy bien y éstas
también tienen una energía cinética que
está provocando que se estén moviendo
muy bien entonces éstas se están
moviendo con cierta velocidad cierta
dirección y lo que vamos a hacer lo que
vamos a pensar es qué pasa cuando
tenemos todo el soluto de este lado
entonces el sistema va a ser que las
moléculas de agua de esta se están
moviendo libremente y pueden ir de de
derecha a izquierda o pueden ir de
derecha de perdón de izquierda a derecha
estas moléculas de azúcar también están
rebotando con cierta velocidad con todas
con todo lo que caracteriza el
movimiento de las partículas y puede ser
que eventualmente digamos por cierta
probabilidad como este túnel digamos o
este puente es suficientemente amplio
para que estas moléculas pasen puede ser
que una de ellas
digamos esta de aquí esta de aquí que
tenemos digamos que es justo está
apuntando hacia el túnel se empieza a
mover a mover a mover y atraviesa este
túnel que conecta los dos contenedores
ok y entonces si lo atraviesa terminará
por ejemplo aquí correcto entonces éste
ya no estará aquí y ahora terminará de
este lado ok entonces eso fue para que
pasara uno de estos de estos de estas
moléculas de azúcar y pero eventualmente
puede dejarse pasar el tiempo y a lo
mejor éste termina rebotando
hasta que también llega a este lado del
contenedor o este contenedor digamos muy
bien entonces lo que pasó al final es
que con cierta probabilidad que es muy
alta
las moléculas del soluto quedan bien
distribuidas entre ambos contenedores
muy bien aquí por supuesto tenemos
cuatro un ejemplo de cuatro moléculas
pero en realidad estamos hablando de
millones y millones entonces a la larga
lo que ocurre es que en ambos
contenedores quedan aproximadamente la
misma concentración de moléculas de
soluto ok por supuesto aquí la
probabilidad de que éste regrese pues
también es muy alta por eso estamos
hablando de millones de moléculas ok si
tienes tiempo suficiente terminan a la
misma digamos con la misma concentración
de ambos lados pero qué fue lo que
ocurrió aquí lo esencial es que de todos
modos en este proceso hemos pasado de un
contenedor con alta concentración a un
contenedor de baja concentración muy
bien aquí teníamos cuatro y terminamos
con dos entonces
es la idea de la difusión muy bien
entonces todo esto es la misma idea de
la difusión pero hablando en soluciones
ok esto fue la difusión y solo para ir
aprendiendo otras palabras importantes
con respecto a estos procesos de
difusión nosotros cuando empezamos con
cuatro moléculas estaba teníamos una muy
alta concentración muy bien tenemos una
concentración de cuatro moléculas
mientras que aquí había nada de
moléculas de azúcar entonces decimos que
esta solución esta solución de la
izquierda cuando teníamos cuatro estaba
era una concentración alta por supuesto
era concentración
alta y eso tiene un nombre decimos que
es una solución hipertónica vamos a
vamos a ponerlo así solución
hipertónica
hiper tónica entonces qué significa una
solución hipertónica que había mucha
concentración del soluto ahora qué fue
lo que ocurrió después
después tuvimos que había una
concentración bueno más bien al inicio
teníamos una concentración menor del
lado derecho verdad no teníamos una
concentración baja digamos no teníamos
moléculas de azúcar y en ese caso
decimos que la solución que había del
lado derecho era una solución hipotónico
tipo tónica muy bien entonces quizás tú
ya has oído este tipo de prefijos en el
hiper y el hipo cuando uno dice hiper de
está diciendo que hay mucho de algo y
cuando uno dice hipo está diciendo que
hay muy poco de algo por ejemplo a lo
mejor tú tienes algún familiar que que
es hipertenso es decir que tiene
hipertensión quiere decir que su presión
es muy alta o que puede ser que tengas
un familiar hipotenso y quiere decir que
su presión es muy baja entonces estos
dos prefijos son bastante útiles para
reconocer algunas propiedades de los
sistemas sobre todo que estamos hablando
en biología y en
química muy bien entonces en general así
como tuvimos la difusión aquí no no
había alguna barrera digamos que que
editará el paso de las sustancias
entonces tendremos que el soluto se
moverá desde una concentración
hipertónica aunque ya una solución
hipertónica a una solución hipotónico es
decir estamos diciendo que de donde hay
una concentración alta la solución se va
a difundir para transportarse hacia
dónde está la concentración baja muy
bien ahora vamos a hacer un experimento
interesante aquí hemos hablado de
difusión y hasta ahora hemos estado
hablando de la difusión del soluto muy
bien estamos pensando que el soluto es
el que se está difundiendo y en general
este no siempre es el caso si si si
quieres ser lo más general posible el
soluto
bueno vamos a hacer este experimento
para expresar estas ideas que tengo que
enseñarles vamos a bajar un poco
entonces digamos ahora que tienen
ustedes un medio digamos un medio en
donde hay mucha agua muy bien entonces
tenemos mucha agua muchas moléculas de
agua aquí ahí tienen sus moléculas de
agua y vamos a pensar que aquí hay una
especie de membrana hay como una hay una
región delimitada por esta membrana muy
bien entonces por supuesto aquí el agua
está muy concentrada afuera pero también
hay agua adentro ok entonces vamos a
poner que hay agua dentro de esta de
esta membrana
entonces esta membrana va a corresponder
al caso que teníamos de nuestro
contenedor aquí tenemos un contenedor de
que tiene agua y lo que está fuera de la
membrana le vamos a llamar el ambiente
externo muy bien entonces tenemos el
ambiente externo y también tenemos un
ambiente interno y así es como definimos
digamos este sistema de una membrana muy
bien entonces el agua puede entrar y
salir puede entrar y salir a través de
esta membrana puede entrar y salir a
través de esta membrana pero si nosotros
agregamos un soluto digamos vamos a
pensar en nuestras moléculas de azúcar
digamos que se encuentren únicamente en
el interior esta membrana vamos a
pedirle que tenga una propiedad de que
no deje salir a las a las moléculas de
azúcar digamos pueden pensar que el
túnel que teníamos acá arriba era mucho
más angosto y no permitía pasar a las
moléculas de azúcar muy bien entonces
estas se van a quedar dentro de la
membrana y vamos a decir vamos a seguir
con el ejemplo de que el soluto es
así que tenemos agua en el exterior y
también dentro de la membrana y tenemos
las moléculas de azúcar dentro de la
membrana por supuesto el solvente no
necesariamente tienen que ser agua puede
ser por ejemplo aire puede ser no sé
quizás mercurio pero para fines
biológicos y químicos
generalmente el soluto es agua muy bien
entonces lo que tenemos son muchas más
moléculas de agua y estoy tratando de
mostrar lo siguiente esta membrana tiene
la propiedad de ser semipermeable ok
entonces la membrana es semi permeable
semi permeable nuevamente esto nos está
diciendo que si deja pasar las moléculas
de agua de un lado a otro pero no deja a
otras moléculas como las del azúcar muy
bien entonces vamos a notar esas
propiedades el agua puede pasar el agua
puede pasar pero pero el azúcar no el
azúcar
a azúcar
no puede no puede pasar a través de la
membrana eso puede ser digamos vamos a
hacer un zoom vamos a vamos a acercarnos
mucho digamos esto es lo que veríamos en
la membrana digamos que esta es la pared
de la membrana y tiene algunos agujeros
por donde puede pasar el agua muy bien
entonces por acá tendremos en el medio
exterior
tendremos moléculas de agua tendremos
moléculas de agua y también tendremos
moléculas de agua en el interior pero
quedamos que en el interior
digamos esta es la parte interior
tenemos además moléculas de azúcar
entonces aquí puede que tengamos
nuestras moléculas de azúcar muy bien
ahí lo tienen
y estamos pensando que aunque se estén
moviendo y tengan una velocidad y estén
chocando contra todas las otras
moléculas de agua o de azúcar en
realidad éstas no pueden pasar por estos
orificios así que vamos a empezar a
utilizar nuestra terminología digamos
este que ya hemos desarrollado quiere
decir que el interior de esta membrana
es una solución hipertónica verdad aquí
del lado interior es una solución
hipertónica mientras que del lado
exterior es hipotónico verdad y fotónica
esto corresponde aquí a hipo tónica
aquí afuera muy bien entonces recordando
que el azúcar es nuestro absoluto y el
agua es nuestro disolvente la membrana
semipermeable muy bien entonces por
supuesto el exterior tiene una menor
concentración de soluto por eso es que
le llamamos hipo tónica ahora si estás
estás está digamos estos orificios
fueran lo suficientemente grandes por
efectos de la difusión estas moléculas
podrían salir y entrar salir y entrar y
a la larga estarán en la misma
proporción de hecho sabríamos que irían
esencialmente de la de la zona
hipertónica a la zona hipotónico pero
como los orificios son mucho más
pequeños entonces va a pasar algo
interesante
lo que va a ocurrir es que estas
moléculas aunque aunque el agua si puede
entrar y salir digamos el agua así puede
entrar y salir lo que va a ocurrir es
que estas moléculas de azúcar puede ser
que estén concentradas en en determinado
momento en los orificios en donde el
agua puede salir entonces el agua al
querer salir en realidad rebota con
estas moléculas de azúcar y no les está
permitiendo que salgan sin embargo como
no hay azúcares acá afuera el agua si
puede seguir entrando a través de estos
orificios entonces qué pasa a la larga
al final este sistema también va a
tender al equilibrio porque quizás acá
afuera hay muy poquitas digamos muy
poquitas moléculas de azúcar y lo que
está pasando es que esencialmente el
flujo de agua es hacia adentro va de la
zona hipotónico a la zona hipertónica
muy bien entonces lo que va a pasar es
que en efecto va a haber mucha menos
agua del lado del en la en la zona en la
que en la zona exterior de esta membrana
con respecto a la zona interior va a
haber mucha más agua acá dentro entonces
la proporción que va a haber entre las
moléculas de azúcar y las moléculas de
agua va a ser esencialmente la misma que
la que hay de este lado solo que aquí va
a haber mucha agua con mucho y con mucho
absoluto y aquí va a haber menos agua
con menos soluto por eso es que decimos
que también va a estar en equilibrio sin
embargo lo que va a pasar es que el agua
va a ir de la zona hipotónico a la zona
hipertónica que es quizás el punto en
donde la gente puede confundirse pero
solo es una cuestión muy sencilla verdad
entonces ya no voy a dar muchos más
detalles aquí pero la idea es que el
agua es el solvente y en este caso el
agua como solvente es el que se va a
mover por efectos de la difusión a
través del de nuestra membrana
semipermeable y esto tiene nombre y se
le conoce como osmosis voy a escribirlo
osmosis este es el proceso de ósmosis
quizás tú ya has oído este término
verdad cuando cuando los maestros te
dicen que el 11 no puede aprender por
ósmosis eso te están diciendo que a lo
mejor si pones un libro contra tu cabeza
tal vez se vaya a filtrar el aprendizaje
en tu cerebro es la misma idea verdad es
de dónde proviene la palabra esta idea
de que el agua se filtre a través de las
membranas para hacer concentraciones más
iguales digamos
eso es lo que define la ósmosis así que
solo el sistema se está moviendo de
forma probabilística no hay magia aquí
entrará más agua para tratar de
equilibrar la concentración muy bien y
finalmente sí sí tal vez unas moléculas
digamos digamos si ya llegamos a un
punto en donde las concentraciones de
agua con respecto al soluto son iguales
entonces el agua empezará a moverse de
derecha a izquierda con la misma
probabilidad entonces llegaremos a una
especie de equilibrio muy bien entonces
lo que quiero dejar muy claro es que la
ósmosis es la difusión del agua y
normalmente tú estarás hablando de la
difusión de agua como un solvente y
generalmente es el contexto en una de
una membrana semipermeable semipermeable
perdón donde el soluto real no puede
viajar a través de la membrana de todas
formas espero que hayas encontrado esto
muy útil y que no te haya resultado tan
confuso